hey everyone this is Kevin from the
chesswebsite.com and today we're going
to be going over a trap in the Sicilian
Dragon 11 fish which is one of the most
common lines that you'll see in the
Sicilian Dragon so Sicilian starts out
with E4 C5 and then after Knight F3 we
see D6 D4 we see the exchange on D4 and
then after Knight F6 Knight C3 Pawn G6
signifying we do have the dragon
variation preparing defianchetta the
bishop to G7 kind of that modern
approach of trying to control the center
of the board with these minor pieces on
the flanks here and then the 11 fish is
F4 I think this is becoming even more
popular in the dragon
variation but F4 from White and then
after Bishop G7
Pawnee five it's usually how white it's
going to continue then after the pawn
takes and pawn recaptures this is the
Trap we are laying for our opponent
because the knights under attack
but the Knight really should be coming
back to D7 which looks somewhat awkward
but usually they fall into playing
Knight D5 comes to the center of the
board gets out of Harm's Way seems like
initially because then I if it just
takes okay well the queen comes down
here the queen and the bishop are both
eyeing down this Pawn on E5 doesn't have
a lot of protection usually you have the
Knight on F3 here from white to protect
but doesn't have that so in this case
you know Black's in a really good
position
and just coming back and bringing the
Knight to D7 best move it's blocking the
queen from controlling the D file it's
blocking out the light Square Bishop so
it seems kind of weird so it's very very
easy for black to fall into this trap of
playing Knight to D5 in one of the most
common variations in the Sicilian dragon
and the reason it's a trap is because
once they played Knight to D5 white has
the move Bishop B5 and that's what we're
going to be looking at today on why this
is such a powerful move from whites and
why this is a common trap that you can
deploy on your opponent so there's
really four variations we're going to
look at the first one is Bishop to D7
blocking it we also could see Knight to
D7 we'll look at why both of those fail
uh Knight to C6 if they want to block it
different way or if they play King f8
so the first version we're going to look
at is Bishop D7 you can see both Bishop
D7 and Knight t7 both have the same
issue and that is they're blocking off
the queen from protecting the Knight and
so white can just take here on the D5
yes black could capture our Bishop
that's fine but we can just take with
our Knight here on uh B5 and then yeah
they could take Pawn on E5 just trying
to gain some material back but we Castle
on the king side maybe they Castle on
the king side you can see well they have
six pawns we have Five Pawns we're up a
minor piece and being up a minor piece
in this position is going to be
extremely extremely valuable for white
should have a pretty easy game from here
now if they don't take on B5 because
remember we can just take this and if
you're up in material you typically want
to trade down because closer you get to
the in-game if you're up in material
it's going to be much easier for you to
turn that into a win so they may decide
okay trading down is not good I need my
Bishops on board so let's not do that
they could try Pawn E6 opening up for
their Queen to get involved into the
game attacking this Knight you want to
get that away but we're just gonna play
Knight F6 check okay well now they uh
take with their Bishop we take with our
Pawn uh they take with their Queen
remember we were giving up that pawn
anyway on E5 because it didn't have a
good Defender and now we can play Knight
F3 so same situation where black has six
pawns white has Five Pawns but we also
have that additional minor piece so it's
going to be extremely good for white now
same problem for black is even if they
don't play Bishop D7 if they played
Knight D7 well it's still blocking off
the queen from protecting this so Knight
D5
now they could Castle on the king side
we play Bishop G5 uh and we're still in
a pretty good spot now they could you
know take that pawn on E5 but we're
still gonna be up that minor piece now
they could just say okay well let's
block it with our Knights on C6 but we
also want to make sure that the queen is
still protecting this Knight on D5 the
problem is it doesn't actually help the
calls because we can take the Knight on
C6 now if they take with their Pawn we
take with our Bishop you can see check
and we are forking The Rook on A8 they
could block with their Bishop I think
they pretty much have to and we're not
going to take the Rook on A8 because
they're just going to recapture we
actually have a better move and that's
the queen taking on D5 we're still
threatening The Rook on A8 but now we've
just taken a free minor piece things are
looking good for us if they play Rook C8
they definitely don't want our Bishop to
take it now we can Castle on the k
kingside and the reason we Castle is one
for
King safety but also if you look at it
this is an additional threat because if
you look at this bishop on C6 they move
their Rook over 2 C8 now they have their
bishop and their Rook both attacking
this bishop on C6 uh but they may say
okay yeah let's let's go ahead and take
on C6 because they can't recapture but
that's no longer the threat once White
Castle's on the king side white has the
threat of Queen takes on F7 now it's
protected by The Rook on F1 black is
going to be completely exposed and going
to be running around so they play King
D7 and then you can probably see Rook to
D1 and this is all she wrote there's no
way to hold on to the queen they could
block it if they wanted to but they're
just going to be giving up an additional
piece here on D5 so that's not going to
work at all if we come back the best
move Knight to C6 we looked at is not
going to be the best move the best move
from them is King f8 now I say best
relatively because there are they've
already fallen for the Trap and White's
gonna have a pretty easy game in my
opinion but King to f8 is the best play
because all the other options of just
blocking uh this Bishop from attacking
the king all failed from what we looked
at but now white has Castle on the king
side and we're attacking this weekend
Square here on F7 anytime you feel in
keto to one side of the board you know
fianca this bishop to G7 you typically
want to be castling you don't want to
put your King on f8 that is going to be
very very difficult for black to hold on
a secure spot now if they play you know
Knight to C6 we can play Queen F3 and
you can see we're attacking a lot we're
attacking the center of the board Knight
on D5 is under attack by both our Knight
and our Queen here but we're also
attacking the F7 Square
which does not have a really good way to
be defended from black so that is the
Sicilian Dragon 11 fish trap it is a
good one one of the reasons I always
like to play the 11 fish uh against the
Sicilian dragon is just because it's so
easy for them to fall into the Trap but
just make sure you bring your Bishop
here to B5 don't capture the Knight on
D5 recognize its mistake and then you
can pounce on this so thank you guys so
much for watching this video hopefully
you enjoyed and I'll see you guys in the
next video